was the president in any way pushing a
false narrative in that call with the
afghan president i think it's pretty
clear again i'm not going to go into
details of a private conversation weird
i noticed that uh she had no problem
speaking repeatedly about things like
the seal dossier for four years
meanwhile the afghanistan situation
continues to fall completely apart uh it
is a disaster area but the good news is
that the biden administration their
their arm has has grown to three feet
long so that they can really tap
themselves on the back pat themselves on
the back uh stroke themselves in every
way possible tuban all over themselves
uh they can they can do all of these
things now physically they've pretzeled
themselves in order to make all of this
happen ron klein who's the shadow
president for joe biden who spends all
day on twitter retweeting things i mean
he's basically like trump on twitter he
uh he
he said yesterday that the afghan
pull-out was handled as well as humanly
possible
it's easy to second guess but let's just
be clear america was in this war for 20
years and i think any effort to unwind
that any effort to bring our troops out
any effort to end our military presence
in afghanistan was going to be filled
with
heartbreaking scenes and difficulties
and i think the biden administration has
managed that as well as it can be
managed under the circumstances we were
placed in
the circumstances you placed yourselves
in it was handled as well as could be
managed and then lloyd austin
the secretary of defense he came out he
said this was historic we're so good at
this man we are so good at this so a few
things one
this is not dunkirk okay we're doing
this under cover of night with the nazis
looking down at british troops and then
a flotilla of small fishing boats being
sent across the english channel this was
planes going in and out of a runway
under no fire
that's what this was and you guys
failing to facilitate that and getting
american troops killed that's what this
was here's lloyd austin again just keep
just keep stroking yourself man keep
keep doing it
now we have just concluded the largest
air evacuation of civilians in american
history
it was heroic
it was historic
and i hope that all americans will unite
to thank our service members for their
courage and their compassion
they were operating in an
immensely dangerous and dynamic
environment
but our troops were tireless
fearless
and selfless
my favorite is when he says things like
this is the biggest evacuation in
american history aren't we good at this
there wouldn't have been an evacuation
necessary if you hadn't pursued an
entirely garbage policy by the way when
people say things like this is
unprecedented dunkirk involved 340 000
troops being evacuated from the french
coastline so actually this is actually
it's pretty well historically
precedented
in the aftermath of the 1948 war
establishing the state of israel from
800 000 people their journeys from arab
lands to israel jews they've been
expelled that was facilitated right so
no large population in the in the
aftermath of the saddam hussein kuwait
war there were huge population transfers
that were facilitated so no this is not
unprecedented no it's not particularly
logistically impressive from the
secretary of defense's perspective and
yes our people on the ground are brave
and heroic but our leadership is just
garbage all the way through
meanwhile i am amazed at the spectacle
of the biden administration saying that
you know people should have gotten out
early we were telling them they needed
to get out earlier and then they didn't
get out earlier so if they got stuck
it's really their own fault there's only
one problem with that which is that joe
biden is a damned liar you'll remember
in july he said the government was not
going to fall now he's like well we were
telling people back in march they should
leave really in july you were saying the
government wasn't going to fall not only
that in july the president of the united
states called up the the
then afghan president ashraf ghani
and some of the transcript has now been
leaked this was july 23rd
and he was telling gani to lie to
everybody and say that everything was
hunky-dory how are you expecting people
to take you seriously when you are
actively encouraging the presidents of
afghanistan to lie about the situation
being just fine
there's only one reason that joe biden
wanted that the one reason that joe
biden wanted that is to shore up his own
domestic political failures
he didn't want people to know that
things were collapsing that quickly
because then everybody had been like
whoa maybe it was a bad idea to announce
to your mortal enemy the taliban what
date you were going to leave how you're
going to leave and then withdraw all air
support
here's what biden said to ghani it's
unbelievable remember donald trump was
impeached over ukraine phone call there
are some problems with that phone call
nothing to me approaching the level of
the president of the united states
calling up the afghan president and
telling him to overtly lie to the world
about the military situation on the
ground in afghanistan
here is what biden said quote
you know i'm a moment late but i mean it
sincerely hey look i want to make it
clear i'm not a military man any more
than you are but i have been meeting
with our pentagon folks and our national
security people as you have been with
ours and yours and as you know and as i
need not tell you the perception around
the world and in parts of afghanistan i
believe is that things aren't going well
in terms of the fight against the
taliban and there is a need whether it
is true or not there is a need to
project a different picture
there's a need to project a different
picture
i mean like that's amazing he's telling
him overtly to lie by the way he also
lied to him this way he said we're going
to continue to make sure your air force
is capable of continuing to fly and
provide air support that's what he told
ghani in july lie he did not continue to
provide air support he he withdrew all
military contractors from the country
he said in addition to that we're going
to continue to fight hard diplomatically
politically economically make sure your
government not only survives but is
sustained and grows because it is
clearly in the interest of the f of the
people of afghanistan that you succeed
and that you lead
i find you a brilliant and honorable man
but the perception is that things are
falling apart
and uh we need that perception to change
it's not about the reality on the ground
changing ghani replied said mr president
we're facing a full-scale invasion
composed of taliban full pakistani
planning logistical support at least at
10 to 15 000 international terrorists
predominantly pakistanis thrown into
this so this so that dimension needs to
be taken account of
he said what is crucial right is ghani
speaking to biden and there's a leaked
transcript of a phone call the binding
will not be impeached over what is
crucial is that close air support and if
i could make a request if your
assistance particularly to our air force
be front loaded because what we need at
this moment there was a very heavy
reliance on air power we have
prioritized that if it could be at all
front loaded we will greatly appreciate
it
okay so and and biden didn't do any of
that and then he said look close air
support works only if there is a
military strategy on the ground to
support so he overtly ref he said we're
going to give you the air support and
god is like okay well we'd like to see
it he's like well you're not getting it
and then he says well why didn't people
leave earlier while i was encouraging
the president
what a
what a dishonest piece of work the
president of the united states is
okay so jen saki was asked specifically
about this pathetic phone call from
president of the united states urging
the afghan president to lie to the
general public while withdrawing close
air support and uh and she of course
dodged the question i'll circle back
around
there's some reporting that we like to
confirm regarding a call in june in july
rather between president biden and
former afghanistan president ghani is
that accurate can you tell us a little
bit more about that
well i'm not going to get into private
diplomatic conversations or leaked
transcripts of phone calls was the
president in any way pushing a false
narrative in that call with the afghan
president i think it's pretty clear
again i'm not going to go into details
of a private conversation
oh you're not going to go into details
it's not private anymore it's right out
there are you saying it's not true
because we've seen it
so so her play is
this thing that was unclass that was
classified has now been leaked the
entire american public can see it it's
on the headline of every major newspaper
in the world
i won't comment because it was
classified and now you've all read it
weird i noticed that she had no problem
speaking repeatedly about things like
the seal dossier for four years
meanwhile we are learning that a
majority of afghans who had worked for
the us military and applied for special
immigrant visas had not been
successfully evacuated and remained in
afghanistan a senior state department
officials said it appeared that a
majority
a majority are still there
according to the senior official i don't
have an estimate for you on the number
of sivs and family members who are still
there i would say it's the majority of
them just based on anecdotal information
about the populations we were able to
support
state department spokesperson ned price
said that of about 31 000 people
evacuated from afghanistan to the united
states between august 17th and august
31st roughly 23 000 were afghan allies
and family members considered at risk by
the taliban
the effort was hampered by the
unpredictable role of the taliban
stationed along routes into the airport
the officials said the taliban
cooperated in some cases but in other
cases blocked afghan nationals from
proceeding to the airport according to
the official
on tuesday based on the initial figures
then available from the pentagon nbc
news reported 8 500 afghan allies had
been evacuated it was not clear if all
of those 8 500 were applicants for sivs
or other expedited visas on wednesday
the pentagon then released new figures
saying that about 20 000 afghans had
arrived at eight military bases in the
united states
he said there are also another 40 000
afghan evacuees but did not provide a
breakdown on how many of these people
were actually screened who these people
were were they sivs were they
translators basically what happened is
that at the very beginning they just
loaded people on planes and took them
they didn't screen any of them that's
that's probably what was happening at
the very beginning the reason i say this
is because you could literally see the
afghan swarming the runway as all of
this was happening
all of which has driven the washington
post
to correctly point out that this is a
disaster area they say this is again the
washington post editorial board quote
this is a moral disaster unattributable
not to the actions of military and
diplomatic personnel but to mistakes
strategic and tactical by mr biden and
his administration correct
the biden administration says the
washington post says they will not be
forgotten plans already are being
developed officials say for continued
efforts to extract people nearly a
hundred nations issued a statement etc
any assurances by the taliban clash with
statements their spokesperson made
during the crisis that the united states
was wrongly inducing afghans to leave
so even the washington post is like yeah
this is just nonsense by the way u.s
citizens are still stranded there they
said no one told them to leave
according to the new york post a
terrified american citizen who was an
interpreter for the us military has said
she's now stranded in afghanistan
because nobody told her the last flights
were leaving on monday
the interpreter was using the pseudonym
for safety she said i just found out
that the last u.s troops left i was just
silent for a while i can't believe no
one told me this is the last fraud the
last flight she says they left us to
whom to those people who wanted to
always kill us
it's heartbreaking i still had hoped
that we would leave
she said she repeatedly attempted to get
through to mercy flights at kabul
detailing how she was instructed to hold
up an umbrella and shout out a code word
but nothing worked to get past the
checkpoints in the thousands trying to
flee
she as if americans couldn't help me
when they were on the ground what the
hell do they expect to do now
she says that she is sheltering 37
people at her house including 19
children two of whom are disabled
so really well done it was a historic
success a historic success
amazing the state department
spokesperson ned price
who is basically the baghdad bob of this
operation
he says you know he's asked so you guys
said that there would be other ways for
americans to escape are you aware of any
americans who have left since the united
states abandoned in afghanistan a couple
of days ago no answer
did you have a number for have any
americans gotten out since that last
flight i i don't have uh i don't have
data to provide on that front
okay now this is doing some pretty
severe damage to joe biden as well it
should according to civics polls right
so they have polls of presidential
approval in every state
his approval rating
has dropped by 11 points in arizona four
in colorado 11 in florida 13 in georgia
nine in michigan four in minnesota four
in nevada seven in new mexico 12 in
north carolina 12 in pennsylvania 25 in
texas six in virginia and six in
wisconsin
those are really bad numbers for the
presidents of the united states and
heading into 2022 this looks like
wipeout territory for the democrats so
of course they are banking again on
january 6th and the january 6th
commission i just don't think that dog
is going to hunt
there's only one group of people in
power right now there's one man who made
this decision he said it's the head of
the united states government the
decision is disastrous the ramifications
are horrific and he's going to bear the
brunt of the political firestorm that is
to come as well he should
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe